Alice first of all uh congratulations
for your first victory of this year's
campaign this was not an easy one up to
this point this tournament I mean you
lost a couple of games you draw the
first one you drew the first one but
finally you got that elusive Victory
congratulations how do you feel right
now uh yeah I mean this game was
extremely like crazy I think I was like
winning I had a really good position of
the opening um and then like after that
I just somehow I managed to thunder and
then I was like completely losing right
before time control but I managed to
then be winning again and uh I was able
to win but I mean for me it's really
great uh to finally get like a win
because uh obviously the start wasn't so
great for me and uh it's just good for
me to go into the rest day uh on a
positive note we always talk about
confidence we always talk about momentum
in chess uh what did you do after those
difficult losses to get back back
psychologically into this
tournament uh I mean I just did what I
normally do I'm I didn't do too much
because uh I find if I adjust my routine
sometimes it goes like uh it backfires
so um yeah I just did uh like my normal
preparation and uh trying to make sure
that uh I I mean when I did the
preparation I didn't do as much as I did
for the previous rounds um because I
think sometimes at the end of the games
I got like slightly tired and made
unnecessary blenders um but yeah I
didn't do too much but I'm glad that at
least in this game it was able to work
and just to discuss the game and the
critical moments of the game when did
you feel like you're finally taking
over I mean so I played like night G4
and then um it was like it was uh KN G4
at some point um and then she played H3
actually after I played night G4 I was
thinking toward the beginning of the
game right yeah towards the beginning so
like after she played uh H3 I was pretty
happy because uh here um actually when I
play night G4 I thought she could play
F3 and then I hadn't calculated that and
that definitely was something that I
should have calculated um I mean I was
thinking maybe I could take on H2 um but
still something to calculate since the
Knight gets trapped right um but after I
played like Knight G4 H3 and got the
Knight to E4 I thought my position was
at least like uh preferable to play
because um um my knight on e4 can't
really be hooked Away by F3 uh and now
it's I just win in exchange but then
something went wrong it was it was you
you assessed it correctly it was winning
yeah something went wrong and I
mean I kind of missed this like C4 and I
definitely miss Bishop takes C6 um yeah
so here of course if Queen takes C6 she
would play Work takes B5 and uh Rook B7
so uh King C7 I think also she has Rook
takes B5 and then I knew like I would
have to be losing it's just transposed
but then she play Queen A5 because I
suppose it's like an immediate uh win
it's like unless I have a king D5 and
she probably missed King D5 um otherwise
I'd be completely losing wow wow and you
saw this King D5 from afar you were
definitely trying to play um against her
clock as well because she only had 40
seconds she was making those last few
moves and she was only playing on
increment at this point so King to D5
and finally you felt safe with the King
on e4 we kind of
were laughing about the journey that the
king engaged in right you long castled
went back to AA now back to E4 like
exactly how are you feeling when you
finally landed that King on e4 and
realized that she doesn't have a
Checkmate I mean yeah after I play King
D5 I calculated like um that she
probably I didn't see any immediate
checkmat so I was like okay actually I
should probably U be winning and then I
mean I think I mean this decision to go
into the end game was more like because
I mean I Pro I might have had something
else but um it's just very safe and with
the king only4 I think it's a good
decision to go into the end game I
applaud that decision
Alice Alice congratulations guys any
questions quick question for you Alice
just in the moment uh I think it was
move uh 20 it was a bishop
C5 and Kate and I were very enthusiastic
about an exchange sacrifice Rook takes
H3 you decided to snare The Rook why
didn't you sacrifice The Exchange Rook
takes H3 right there wait so instead of
Knight takes F1 yeah well instead of
Knight D2 yes that's
right yeah I I think I considered um Rus
H3 because um I mean of course I was
like considering all the attacks against
the king but I think after uh I thought
like 92 should also be wi need so like
why not and then I kind of like I didn't
realize how much initiative she had
still after um because I was like uh
planning to sorry I was planning to like
uh take the bishop on C5 until I
realized that maybe it wouldn't be as
good um yeah and then hear something
went wrong and then things went wrong
all right Alice well enjoy your rest day
and uh welcome back to the
tournament thank you absolutely
as once again